-This is big, actually.
I saw that the daytime TV show,
"Maury," is ending.
-Oh.
-Yeah. 31 years on the air
is quite a run.
-Oh, man. That's a shame.
"Maury" has been, like,
my favorite show.
-What?
That's not true.
"Maury" is not
your favorite show.
I bet you've never even seen
an episode, you liar.
-[ Scoffs ] Don't you call me
a liar!
You don't even know me!
You're the liar!
[ Audience oohs ]
-No, no, no, no, no. No.
You're the liar.
-Whoa!
-You are!
-Hey, hold on, guys, guys,
calm down, guys.
-Know what? I don't need this.
[Bleep] all y'all.
-Wait, wait, wait, what?!
-Oh, yeah! You heard me!
-Boo!
-Boo him!
-No, no, no, no, no, no! No!
I don't need any of you!
[ Shouts ]
Forget it! [ Fake crying ]
-You better run! Man, that's all
you ever do, is run!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Fake crying ]
-Higgins.
You can't just storm out
every time you get upset.
-You're right.
-You know, you have to learn to
confront your problem,
you know that?
-Yeah, I know that.
-You ready to go back out there?
Let's do it. Let's go back out
there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-[ Continues fake crying ]
-That's alright.
Now, we're going to get to
the bottom of this.
Higgins actually took
a lie detector test
before the show to prove
if he actually watches "Maury."
Alright, and here are
the results.
When asked, "Is 'Maury'
your favorite show?"
Higgins said yes.
The lie detector determined
that was...
a lie!
-Yeah!
-No!
-Yes! I told you!
-[ Cheering ]
-No! No! That's not --
Come on!
-Also, also,
our paternity test determined
you're the father
of 28 illegitimate children.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew that.
-Oh, okay.
Alright, Steve Higgins,
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Stick around, we're playing
charades with Leslie Mann
and Mikey Day when we come back,
everybody.
♪♪